Ich bin wieder da
Aber nicht lang
So jetzt, jetzt funktioniert's
Also ich bin wieder da
Aber wahrscheinlich nicht lang
Weil das Spiel nicht startet
Ich kann das noch nicht mal aninstallen
Achso weil's läuft
Geht nicht
Spiel ist broken
Startet nicht
Es ist der Meinung
Es läuft
Aber es startet nicht
Was für ein Scheiß ist das, Mann
Wie verkacken
Wie unfähiger Scheißhaufen
Kann man sein, Alter
Das ist doch unglaublich
Der Kack startet nicht mal
Ich fasse es nicht so schlecht, Alter
So schlecht
Guckt euch die Scheiße an, Mann
Soll ich es noch mal aninstallen
Oder
Repair, wir machen jetzt Repair
Repairing, Repairing machen wir jetzt
Sogar der OpaPieCher69 ist im Game
Repairing
Leute, wie wär's beim InnerProgress Anzeige für Repairing
41 von 95
MB
95, schwachsinn an
92 Spiel
Das weiste sind wahrscheinlich über den Stream hergekommen
Noch nicht mal die Anzeige
Ergibt irgendwie Sinn
95 als kaputt
So langsam, oder?
Wahrscheinlich sind das 95 GB
Ok, ist angeblich klar
Leute, es ist Repaired
Es ist Repaired, das geht jetzt
Pass auf, es ist Repaired
PostChamp, PostChamp, RepairChamp
Was? Ja
Ok
EasyAntiCheat, alles klar
Lauf als Root, was sonst?
Seit wann muss man da ein Root Passwort eingeben?
Kommt das manchmal vor?
Das geht immer noch nicht
Das ist Placingly Fast Written in Rust
Das sind nur 95 MB groß
Ok, nice
GG
Startet einfach nicht
Das wäre schon längst aufgegangen normalerweise
Ok, nice
Funktioniert Premium Qualität
Funktioniert richtig gut
Soll ich nochmal aninstallen?
Manage
Wenn ich das aninstallen, dauert das so ewig
Bis es wieder runter geladen ist
Mensch
Ich meine
Bei mir ist es auch gestartet eben
Bevor ich den Stream angemacht habe, ging es
All Addons, ah ja
Ich habe es eben versucht ohne OBS zu starten, ging auch nicht
Bevor ich
Bevor ich den Stream angemacht habe, habe ich es gestartet
Es ging
Ok, dann installiert es da
Create Desktop Shot
Super, was machen wir jetzt 20 Minuten lang?
Wisst ihr was?
Wahrscheinlich hätte ich es einfach über Steam kaufen
Kann man seinen Procrast verwenden
Für Origin, wenn man es auf Steam hat
Wie mich das aufregt wieder, Alter
Ich will den Rotz schon gar nicht mehr spielen jetzt
Es kann auch nicht sein, dass es einfach nicht läuft
PuffChamB, aber das Stream laggt wahrscheinlich jetzt, oder?
Laggt das Stream, oh ja
Das sind ein bisschen Frametrops wegen dem Download, aber gut
Du brauchst irgendeinen Browser, den er fernsteuern kann
Ich glaube, Chrome geht auch
Aber das macht ja nichts
Du kannst ja Firefox auch auf deinem Säuber installieren
Ich meine, du brauchst unter der Haube eh einen Browser, den er fernsteuern kann
Du musst einen Browser öffnen
Und das kannst du z.B. per SSHX-Forboding machen
Aber warum willst du auf dem Server einen Chat-GPT-Rapper laufen lassen?
Leute, das wird wahrscheinlich trotzdem nicht funktionieren jetzt
Wir probieren mal kurz was anderes aus
Lass mal kurz checken
Battlefield 3 habe ich nicht, ich traue
Der Repairt nicht, ich lade das neu runter gerade
Kenn die Leute hier alle gar nicht
Das ist auch ein Paar
Aber
Weiß keine, wenn ich da nicht alles in der Liste hab
Was ist das denn?
Was?
Also mein Bock das Spiel zu spielen ist gerade echt auf dem Tiefpunkt.
Ich mein, okay, realistisch betrachtet, ich hab das Spiel geöffnet auf meinem normalen
Windows-Account.
Jetzt hab ich umgelockt auf mein Streaming-Account und jetzt startet's nicht mehr.
Das kann auch nichts mit dem Windows-Account wirklich zu tun haben.
Das kann auch nicht an Origin oder EA App liegen, das hat irgendwelche Probleme mit dem
Anti-Cheat.
Der ist ja auch der Meinung, es läuft und dann läuft es doch nicht.
Kein Schimmer.
Moment, jetzt Repairter?
Warum Repairter denn?
Ich hab eben uninstall, noch nicht mal diese fucking Anzeige stimmt.
Ich hab uninstall und reinstall, der Repairt überhaupt nix.
Ich frag mich echt, ob die noch irgendwie noch ein paar vereinzelte kompetente Entwickler
haben, die sich um den ganzen Kram kümmern.
Da kann jetzt wahrscheinlich DICE gar nicht mal so viel für, weil DICE kann nix für
die App und kann auch sicherlich wenig für den Anti-Cheat.
Also insgesamt, ich mein, was ist das für ein Zustand?
Du installierst ein Game, es sagt, es startet und macht einfach gar nix.
Was ist das?
Soll ich mir jetzt wirklich 19 Minuten mit euch zusammen angucken, wie er den Kack wieder
installiert?
Der war angeblich ja Repairt und nicht installiert.
Kann man die Freundesliste irgendwie ausblenden?
Der Speicher, die Settings sind einfach, die Settings speichert er hier, Documents Battlefield
2042.
Soll ich mal gucken, ob es noch da ist?
Also ursprünglich installiert war es hier unter Games, ja es ist weg, hier gab es einen
Ordner für Battlefield, hier ist nur Dark drinne, da gab es einen Ordner für Battlefield.
Was, die Settings, nee die Settings brauche ich, ich stell das doch, Quatsch, an den Settings
kann das nicht liegen, das sind die gleichen Settings, wo ich das Game eben mit gestartet
hab.
Ich mein, ich kann die Settings löschen und gucken, aber guck mal, der startet das Game
ja noch nicht mehr, das heißt, es liegt irgendwie am Anti-Cheat, der nicht weiß, was es machen
soll.
Also Laufen war bisher nicht das Problem bei dem Game, gestartet ist es bisher immer.
Was es nicht gemacht hat, ist ordentlich laufen.
Fuck man, jetzt muss ich mir den Kram 17 Minuten angucken, bis es fertig installiert hat.
Ich hab extra vom Stream runtergeladen, installiert, gestartet, es hat gestartet, ich hab dann
Bot-Match gemacht, alles wunderbar funktioniert und jetzt, mach ich den Stream an, versuch
das Game zu starten, es geht einfach nicht mehr.
Das ist unmöglich, Alter.
Okay, was machen wir jetzt 17 Minuten lang, gibt es irgendwas spannendes?
Windows 11 vs XP.
Okay.
Wie Gott und die Welt irgendwas mit Chat-GP-Themen macht, ich muss sagen, ich fand die Sache
nach einer Woche schon wieder uninteressant.
Ruckelts eigentlich, wenn ich streame und downloade, ne, ich hab keine Frametrops, alles gut.
Den neuen Track von Tanzverbot, den kenn ich schon, den kenn ich schon.
Wolltest du nicht bei Windows 10 bleiben, bin ich auch, auf dem alten Rechner bin ich
weiter auf Windows 10 und hab das auch nicht vor, umzustellen.
Auf dem neuen brauch ich Windows 11, da führt kein Weg dran vorbei, allein schon wegen den
KPU-Kern.
Hallo, ich will scrollen, ne, ich will nicht da scrollen, ich will hier scrollen.
Warum Undercover-Boss ekelhaft ist, was zum Teufel ist Undercover-Boss, das hört sich
so nach einer typischen Sendung an, sowas in Richtung Berlin Tag und Nacht und sowas.
Nix, was ich mir im Leben freiwillig angucken würde.
Und was macht Battlefield, 15 Minuten, yeah, vor gut.
Ah, wir haben, wir haben, ne, ich wollte sagen knapp die Hälfte, ne, nicht wirklich.
Große Firmschaft verkleiden sich im Arbeiten, Undercover im eigenen Laden, ne, das wär
vielleicht mal gar nicht so schlecht, wenn es einige machen würden, also, ernsthaft
machen würden und nicht für RTL-Sensations-Shit machen würden.
Was ist das Problem mit Windows, mit CPU und Windows 11, äh, mit Windows 10, das Problem
mit Windows 10 und der CPU ist, äh, ne, hier, dass der 13900K 8 normale Kerne hat und 16
efficiency cores und der Windows 10 Multithreading-CPU-Zeitverwaltungs-Scheduler kommt damit nicht klar und macht
Mist und so, genauso wie ich das eingeschätzt habe bei Microsoft, um den Leuten irgendwie
Windows 11 aufzuzwingen, ähm, gibt es einfach die Neuerung, nicht mehr für Windows 10
und du musst Windows 11 benutzen, wenn du das, wenn du neue Hardware benutzen möchtest
in Zukunft.
Ah ja und meine Tastatur ist verbugt, ich muss die mal kurz rausziehen, die blinkt,
die sollte eigentlich die RGBs auf blau gestellt haben, ja, jetzt, eine ausgesteckt, jetzt
wieder und jetzt kommt gleich blimm diese komische Logitech-Software und sagt mir haha,
du hast das auf 800dpi eingestellt, ja, das ist das, was die Welt gebraucht hat.
13 Minuten noch, bist du mit Windows 11 zufrieden?
Ne, überhaupt nicht.
Abwegs geht die Musikroute ab.
Gibt es Chipsets, die für die Zukunft upgradbar bleiben?
Weil in den, also die letzten paar Generationen hat ja gezeigt, dass die AMD-Dinger relativ
zukunftssicher waren, ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie es aktuell aussieht.
Was stört dich daran, dass zum Beispiel dieser Teil der Taskleiste nie benutzt wird und wenn
ich Fenster switchen will, ich es da drüber machen muss, richtig hängen geblieben.
Und wenn ich mich mal in mich, das ist stört mich wahrscheinlich am meisten, aber wenn
ich mal in mich gehe, würde ich wahrscheinlich noch deutlich mehr finden, aber es gibt an
Windows 10 genauso viel, was mich stört.
Aber das geht unter Windows 10 wenigstens, ich weiß auch nicht, warum die jedes Windows
gefühlt die Taskleiste neu entwickeln müssen.
Ne, kann man nicht mehr umstellen, geht nicht mehr.
Ich war immer bei KeyPass, ich hab das nur mal ein bisschen erprobt und hab den Vorteil
für mich nicht gesehen, rein lokal bei mir, deswegen bin ich weiter bei KeyPass.
Okay Leute, 50% haben wir geschafft.
Predictions, komm Predictions, falls ein Mod da ist, Predictions, ob es jetzt nach dem
neu installieren geht oder nicht, das lasst mal predikten, Prediqchamp.
Wird nicht gehen, ich denke auch nicht, dass es gehen wird.
Aber warum nicht?
Ich mein, was willst du denn jetzt großartig anders machen, als es zu installieren noch
mal?
Habt ihr auch 100% CPU-Auslastung im Hauptmenü?
Ne, ich komm noch nicht mal ins Hauptmenü.
Über Origin installieren, das Spiel startet doch und hängt dann irgendwo bei Anti-Cheat,
das wird weder an EA Play noch an Origin liegen.
Das liegt daran, weil EA wahrscheinlich nicht damit klar kommt, dass ich jetzt den Windows
Account gewechselt habe.
Ich hab das ja vorhin auf meinem normalen Windows Account gespielt und jetzt hab ich
auf den Streaming Account drüber geswitcht.
Ich mein, normalerweise, und das war es in der Vergangenheit nicht, hab ich das ja auch
schon gemacht, ist es eigentlich überhaupt kein Problem.
Die Spiele interessieren sich null dafür, auf welchem Account du bist, zumal du dich
vorher im Launcher hier einloggen musst und da auch alles erkannt wird und es funktioniert.
Und es ging ja auch bisher immer, aber jetzt hat sich EA gedacht, ne, das geht jetzt nicht
mehr.
Okay, wir machen noch mal was, wir gehen mal in Documents, äh, wo benennt man das
nochmal um hier?
Und wir benennen das mal um, in der Hoffnung, dass es vielleicht, wenn die Settings nicht
greifen gehen sollte, neun Minuten.
Display Link Docs, ähm, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das ein Display Link Doc ist, aber
ich habe für, auf der Arbeit, für mein Surface Book 3, habe ich einen Doc und an den Doc
muss man dann per USB den Monitor anschließen, Next Network, das ist egal, ob es Origin oder
EA Play ist, es startet und hängt bei Anti-Cheat und es ging ja vorher auch, das kommt garantiert
nicht mit, mit, irgendwie dem Accountwechsel aus irgendwelchen Gründen klar, das liegt
nicht an all, das wird mich sehr, sehr wundern, wenn das an Origin oder EA Play liegt, weil
das Starten funktioniert doch.
Wenn ich auf dem anderen Accountesspiel starte, funktioniert es auch 10 von 10 Fällen, oder
hast du exakt das gleiche Setup wie ich, dass du es auf einem Account gespielt hast und
dann auf den anderen Windows-Account wechselst?
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Das Surface Doc ist der letzte Rotz, ich bewege es nicht.
Das funktioniert ganz okay.
Wisst ihr, was mir an dem Surface Book wirklich nicht gefällt?
Dass man Fingernägel braucht, um das Display hochzuklappen, die haben es gedacht, das muss
besonders dünn und schwergängig sein, das Display, so einfache Clips wie früher am
Notebook vorne, am Notebook-Deckel zum einfacher Aufklappen gibt es ja nicht mehr, du musst
damit den Fingernägel rein zum Aufmachen, also ergonomisch ist auch was anderes, dafür
ist es ein cooles Display, läuft der Anti-Cheat-Prozess unter dem anderen User, ich habe den Rechner
neu gestartet.
Deswegen installiere ich jetzt einfach mal neu.
Der EA Background Service läuft, hui, aber die EA Background Service, da läuft ja auch
als Service, das hat ja weder mit dem einen User noch mit dem anderen User was zu tun
hat als System, wir werden gleich sehen, ob es funktioniert, sieben Minuten, dass es
auf einem Non-Root-Account gestartet wird, damit kam der auch klar auf dem anderen Rechner
und das wird hier kein Root-Account werden, zumal ich für Anti-Cheat ja mein Root-Passwort
eingeben musste, es kann auch überhaupt nicht sein, dass wir irgendwelche Workarounds brauchen
um ein Spiel zu starten, wo sind wir denn, der Dienst könnte auf automatisch stehen,
wahrscheinlich steht der auf automatisch, aber EA hier, da, da macht ja nichts, ich
meine das läuft als System-User wahrscheinlich, wo sieht man das, ich starte das jetzt aber
auch nicht neu, also es ist egal, es wäre ja auch bescheuern, wenn es was anderes wäre,
Punkbuster nein, ihr habt früher Punkbuster benutzt, Punkbuster ist schon lange lange
lange nicht mehr angesagt, so habe ich mir das nicht vorgestellt, hoffentlich startet
es jetzt wenigstens gleich, ja genau, vor allem für ein neues Spiel Workarounds haben,
aber die Musik ist nice, etwas groß geraten, kannst du Easy Anti-Cheat hier installieren,
ich hätte jetzt fast vermutet, das habe ich hiermit gemacht, ich kann das mal neu starten
hier, easy anti-cheat, wobei es ja läuft ja gar nicht, easy anti-cheat läuft ja gar nicht,
das wird ja schon gemacht haben, ich gehe davon aus, dass es eh für jedes Spiel irgendwie
eine eigene Instanz von gestartet wird, wir werden es gleich sehen, noch 4 Minuten, ach
was ein Kacke, aber ich habe mich da, ich habe mich gerade sowas von drüber aufgeregt,
das kann doch nicht sein, das ist einfach nicht funktioniert, ich wollte jetzt 1-2 Stunden
mit euch Battlefield spielen, außerdem, vor allem, dass ich auch ein bisschen Videomaterial
für morgen habe, ich werde morgen da ein bisschen was zu erzählen, wie es mir so gefällt,
aber dazu muss ich erstens spielen können und zweitens wäre es halt praktisch, wenn
wir einfach zusammen spielen könnten, aber nee, das ist nicht im Scope von EA, dass ihre
Spiele einfach funktionieren, nee, ich habe kein Gigabit von Vodafone, geht auch nicht
so ohne weiteres, dann habe ich dann wieder kein richtiges Dual-Stack mehr und und und,
ich habe Nas ja, ich habe seit einer Weile einen HP Microserver, also die aktuelle Generation,
mit Unraid drauf, ein paar VMs, ein paar Container, ich habe früher Unraid öfters mal geflamed
und nach dem Motto, warum soll ich mir dann Unraid installieren oder irgendwie so ein
Ding mit GUI, wenn ich doch das alles von Hand auf jener Debian oder Ubuntu Kiste machen
kann, aber es ist doch ganz angenehm, muss ich sagen.
Besser kann man nicht sagen, es kommt auf den Anwendungszweck an, einfach nur Netzwerkspeicher
haben willst, wahrscheinlich, ECC-RAM Leute, sonst rasten die im Freenas Forum aus, wenn
du keinen ECC-RAM hast, die springen dir durch den Bildschirm entgegen, übrigens es ist
kein Download, es ist ja offiziell Repairing, sieh mir mal wie kaputt diese Software ist,
ich glaube keine gewünschten MOSFET- 않고 Glけて, ich glaube gerade ein梯ug thanks
Zwei Minuten, Leute. Pause, Champ.
Pause, Pause, Pause, Pause, Pause, Pause, Champ.
Es ist sehr spannend, muss ich sagen. Richtig hier High Octane Gameplay und Streams.
Prediction, ob es startet. Ich bin zu faul. Entweder macht das einer der Mods oder wir lassen die Prediction weg.
Ich bin zu faul, eine Prediction zu machen.
Ich bin schon wieder wahnsinnig motiviert dadurch, dass das Spiel nicht einfach funktioniert.
Aber, das könnte ganz einfach sein. Es geht jetzt und dann ist die erste Runde richtig gut und dann bin ich wieder motiviert.
Aber es gab eine. Moment, was kam da raus?
Stream Manager.
Prediction, ne, wo steht denn das jetzt?
83% auf Nein, ja. Ich tippe auch nicht darauf, dass es jetzt geht.
Okay, Repairing, any moment now, Leute, any moment. Jetzt, jetzt ist soweit.
Es hebt ab.
I gamble, danke schön für den Zap.
Any moment now, Repairing.
Du hättest einfach nur den Anti-Cheat aninstallen müssen. Ah, okay, du weißt das also, woran das liegt.
Wo aninstalle wo aninstallt man denn den Anti-Cheat?
Mein Vater arbeitet bei er genau.
Okay. Ja, soweit waren wir schon mal. Passwort eingeben haben wir auch schon mal geschafft.
Moment, Moment. Nein, dauert schon wieder so lange.
Okay, Reinstall hat nicht geholfen.
Battlefields als Atmosphäre.
Battlefields als Admin starten.
Anti-Cheat Engine. Okay, wir starten jetzt die Anti-Cheat Engine von Hand. So, nice. Jetzt habe ich die Anti-Cheat Engine von Hand gestartet. Und jetzt?
Und den EA Background Service auch neu starten. Alles klar, easy.
Aha, okay, geht immer noch nicht.
Easy Anti-Cheat Launcher.
Okay, ich soll Anti-Cheat installieren, ja? Also, Control Panel, uninstall. Easy. Gibt es so überhaupt nicht.
Oder vielleicht hier? Easy. Gibt es nicht.
Was für dumme Geschwätze wieder im Chat, Alter. Wahnsinn.
Easy Anti-Cheat Installer.
Easy Anti-Cheat Setup. Das ist nicht kaputt.
Meinst du mal nach Anti-Cheat suchen? Ja, okay, können wir auch machen. Anti. Anti. Nee. Control.
Anti. Nope. Dein Link ist ein Link auf Easy Anti-Cheat. Das macht doch der Launcher für mich.
Warum soll ich von Hand Anti-Cheat installieren? Zumal, wenn ich den Account umloge, wird es wahrscheinlich funktionieren.
Gut, also das funktioniert nicht. Settings habe ich auch umbenannt. So, wir haben lange genug gewartet.
Doch, ich habe den Link angeklickt. Da steht drin, dass man irgendeine Anti-Cheat-Geschichte als Repair ausführen soll.
Oh, ich habe den Chat ja hier gar nicht auf.
Ups. Moment. Ist mein... Nein. Chat. Okay.
So. Pass auf, Chat. Der Link rettet uns jetzt.
You can also install service manually. Navigate to the Easy Anti-Cheat folder inside of the game installation folder. Locate Easy Anti-Cheat Setup. Okay.
Alles klar. Machen wir jetzt. In welchem Folder ist denn der Krämpel überhaupt? C. Doppelpunkt. Backslash.
Kann man irgendwo Installationsfolder öffnen? Das ist wahrscheinlich auch nicht im Scope gewesen, das zu sehen. Properties. Ah ja, hier. Okay.
Ah, ne, ne, ne. Copy-pasten geht da natürlich nicht. Copy-pasten geht da nicht. Also. C. Doppelpunkt. Program Files.
EA Games. Okay, so. Mal alles abschießen, ne? Mal mal alles zu. Ja, nervt nicht rum, Game. Easy Anti-Cheat Launcher.
Ja, ja. Easy. Easy as fuck. EA Desktop. EA. Alles weg. Okay, ist alles, alles, alles weg. Okay.
EA Desktop. EA. Alles weg. Okay, ist alles, alles aus. Gut. So, Battlefield. Easy Anti-Cheat. Easy Anti-Cheat Setup.
Launch it as administrator and choose Install. Game 609. Repair.
Das war's jetzt? Ich könnte wetten, das hat absolut keine Auswirkungen jetzt.
So, ich, ich mach euch weg, dass, dass ich nicht auswähle. Irgendwelche Credentials leake oder so, wenn ich mich anmelde.
So. Ich will, in Wirklichkeit will ich nur mal Anti-Cheat verstecken. Denke ich sollte klar sein. Okay. Play.
Play. Yes. Nö, geht wieder nicht. Nope.
Nee, ich hab eben fünf Minuten oder so gewartet. Der Screen geht jetzt gleich weg und das Spiel launst nicht.
Sehr gut. Nice. EA. Nice. Sehr gut. Sehr gut. Das habt ihr ganz toll gemacht, EA. Ganz toll.
Ich mein, was soll ich machen? Ich hab Anti-Cheat reinstallt. Ich hab das Game reinstallt. Ich hab die Settings umbenannt.
Ach ja, ich als, als Administrator starten kann ichs noch. Oder was, was? Was soll ich überhaupt als Administrator starten? Das hier?
Connecting to EA App. It's already running. Kackel. Ja, ist es eben nicht.
Aber den Easy Anti-Cheat Launcher mal wieder aus. Dann denkt er nämlich dieses aus. Jawoll.
So. Trial. Was davon soll ich ihn starten? Als Administrator. Komm, wir starten das als Administrator. Why not?
Okay. Nö. Na vielleicht, nee. Geil. Das hat EA immer wieder richtig gut hinbekommen.
Ich starte jetzt sicherlich nicht mein PC neu. Nee, das wird nicht funktionieren. Das dauert schon zu lang.
Nee, es liegt nicht an OBS. Ich hab's eben versucht zu starten ohne OBS. Hat auch nicht funktioniert.
Easy Anti-Cheat Launcher. Was will der eigentlich? Ja. Da läuft's. Macht's aber nicht. Okay. Was soll man noch probieren?
Ich kann den ja auch als Administrator starten meinetwegen. Ich hab auf reparieren gedrückt. Korrekt.
Ich kann die Windows Firewall einfach mal ausmachen. Wo geht das überhaupt? Hier? Nee. Wo schaltet man die Windows Firewall aus?
Windows Defender Firewall. Ja. On. John, Windows Defender Firewall off. Ja. Wer weiß. Wer weiß, wer weiß, wer weiß.
Nicht so easy, ne? Versuch mal im Launcher die Spielsprache zu ändern. Was? Okay. Warum nicht?
Das ist von der Beta.
Das hat keinen Bock.
Properties. Ähm. Wartet mal. Wo hab ich den Prozessor Explorer hier? Admin.
Wir müssen mal nach Easy Anti-Cheat gucken hier. Easy Anti-Cheat. Sieht man als welcher User das läuft?
Kann man als User nehmen? System und so ist eigentlich alles okay.
Tja. Okay, also an der Firewall lag das jetzt auf jeden Fall auch nicht.
Also jetzt fällt mir ehrlich gesagt nichts mehr ein.
Lad einfach neu runter. Hä? Warum soll ich nochmal neu runterladen? Das gibt doch gar keinen Sinn.
Die Sprache im Launcher umstellen. Okay. Wo? Die Spielsprache umstellen. Bio Properties. Wo macht man das überhaupt?
Lass mal gucken. Wo ist das? Manage? Ja, Manage Properties, oder? Hä? Nee, hier leake ich irgendwelche Sachen, die ich nicht leaken will wahrscheinlich, klar.
Du musst das Spiel neu runterladen. Ja, nee. Alter, das kann doch echt nicht sein jetzt, man.
Also jetzt bin ich wirklich, jetzt sind wirklich meine Ideen aus. Jetzt weiß ich nicht, was ich machen soll, dass das startet.
Drück doch mal Shift, Rechtsklick auf Battlefield und als anderen Benutzer ausfüllen. Das ist eine gute Idee, das kann man machen.
Was Shift, Rechtsklick? Und dann was? Run as different user. Okay. Ich hoffe, dass mein Account Max ist. Mach mal aus, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob ich irgendwas leake oder nicht.
Wahrscheinlich nicht. Oh nee, okay. Nee. Bringt nichts, startet nicht. Guck mal eventuell Log Appdata Roaming. Okay.
Okay, Appdata. Nee, Mensch. Appdata. So. Easy Anti-Cheat Game Launcher. Ja. Okay, da steht jetzt Zeug drinnen. 0%. Yeah, nice.
Nice. Da weiß man richtig Bescheid jetzt, woran es liegt. 100%. Destroying Windows.
MonkaS. 609. Loader. 100%. Tja.
Leute, dann wird das wahrscheinlich nichts mit Battlefield Stream heute. EA sagt, das Spiel möchte nicht mehr starten.
Du kannst easy anti cheat. Ja, gut. Tatsächlich. Das könnte ich noch machen. Ich meine, ich habe schon repariert. Da würde man jetzt eigentlich erwarten, dass es funktioniert. Aber na ja, man, es ist.
Okay, wo ist der Krempel nochmal? EA Games Battlefield Easy Anti-Cheat Setup. Oder einfach. Ich habe das doch schon deinstalliert. Uninstall. Uninstall successfully.
Okay, und jetzt? Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt. Was passiert, wenn ich jetzt auf starten drücke? Installiert er den Anti-Cheat neu?
Launch Error. Easy Anti-Cheat Not Installed. Okay, interessant. Also Easy Anti-Cheat Setup.
Easy Anti-Cheat Finished. Wird auch nichts bringen.
Nö. Ich meine, was könnte es noch sein? Schauen nochmal in das Log. Nee, da stand doch kein Fehler. Welches Log? Das da? Oder hier irgendwas?
Updater. Easy Anti-Cheat Game Launcher. Nö, da stand keine Fehlermeldung. Alles okay.
Das ist im 609 Ort. No Errors. Steht da sogar explizit. Das ist der Crypt of the Necrodancer Soundtrack.
Boah, ist das wieder schlecht alles, Mann.
Es ist so schlecht. Also jetzt habe ich echt keine Idee, was ich machen soll. Nee, ich gucke nicht in Event Viewer.
Hast du die GeForce Experience installiert? Ja, aber hier bin ich glaube nicht eingeloggt.
Boah, dann halt nicht, ne? Shadowplay deaktivieren. Kannst du mal schauen, ob dein User im R-Ordner auf den Certificate License... Nö, sehe ich nicht ein.
...da in meinen Windows-Settings rumzustellen. Windows Game Mode aus habe ich bestimmt aus. Wie schaltet man denn überhaupt ein und aus?
Game Mode ist auf. Okay, Bam, Game Mode ist aus. Ich meine, bringen wir jetzt wahrscheinlich nichts.
Moment, was muss ich denn jetzt beenden nochmal hier? Easy, easy. Das läuft überhaupt nicht mehr. Battlefield? Da läuft überhaupt nichts mehr.
Da läuft überhaupt nichts mehr, was angeblich... Welches Game? Es läuft kein Game mehr. Easy. Battlefield.
Hier, BF20 zu links pumpt Exe. Alles klar. Gut, haben wir auch aus. So, Game Mode ist deaktiviert. Was ein Scheiß, man.
Ich habe keine Leistungsprobleme. Ich habe den schnellsten Desktop Rechner, den man sich zur Zeit kaufen kann.
Das Game lief im anderen Account. Also, es läuft nicht im Hintergrund, aber es lief noch im anderen Account, ja. Na ging's.
Dann habe ich neu gestartet und es ging immer noch nicht. Tja, nö, dann waren wir heute kein Stream. Alles klar, Leute, macht es gut. See you.